pouvait mettre maintenant les prix
d'interprétation masculine j'appelle le
mode moselle jessica chastain
[Musique]
tv one ou soir à tous pays response and
suis ravi d'être avec vous a été une
expérience incroyable pour nous tous
membres du jury qui a le lauréat
vous allez dire quelque chose de plus
vous deviez nous dire quelque chose que
si cabon d'interprétation masculine est
attribué à roy keane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
speak french is et les jeux qui sur moi
je ne peux dire que merci
ce prix est tout à fait inattendu
monsieur mes chaussures ne sont pas ne
sont pas de circonstances
j'ai renvoyé mais sous les vernis
toujours est il que je suis sans voix
un immense merci pour pour ce prix un
grand merci à thierry merci à tout le
monde ici merci à athènes d'amazon
studieux masque alrosa le producteur
line je t'adore et tout ce que j'ai pu
faire était complètement l'oeuvre de de
lynne ramsey
un grand merci à grand mère en 2005 en
europe c'est line rien de nice en 2000
mousse pour ce master il remporte ce
soir son premier trophée cannois un
festival depuis sa première venue en 95
pour patate où il avait déjà présenté
captyn de james gray ainsi que l'homme
opérationnel de woody allen
son rôle d'ancien mariemont mutique et
brutal pour le 2e primaire soirée a dû
voir nick neri d'ikea
pour les prêts
[Applaudissements]